The myth of overpopulation originated in England in 1798,...
...when a vicar named Thomas Malthus who fancied himself something of a mathematician,...
...saw that food production increased incrementally, but people reproduced exponentially.
He sat down and did some simple math...
...and summarily decided that the world would be out of food by 1890.
He blamed reduced mortality rates and recommended killing off...
...the have-nots of society, lest the haves starve to death.
This cry was taken up by Paul Ehrlich of Stanford University in 1968,...
...who claimed that reckless human reproduction had overwhelmed the Earth.
Massive famines would result, which would destroy, best case scenario,...
...one-fifth of humanity by the end of the 70s,...
...and the planet would follow.
This fear produced large donations for the newly created UNFPA,...
...which thrives on an imagined crisis that has been both imminent...
...and rescheduled again and again over the past two centuries.
The truth of the matter is that every family on this planet could have a house with a yard...
...and all live together on a landmass the size of Texas,...
...which is really just a small corner of the planet.
The population growth will peak in 30 years and then start to go back down.
We're not overpopulated.
Do the math.